THE SCENE COMING UP.
BUT, FIRST, GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
MOST CHEERFUL HOLIDAY SEASON
IMAGINABLE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FOR THREE YEARS THEY FAST
SIZED ABOUT IMPEACHING
DONALD TRUMP, LURE RID
VISION OF TRIALS,
CONVICTION, THE HELICOPTER
LIFTING OFF FROM THE LAST
TIMES FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
LAWN TO THE SUSTAINED
APPLAUSE TO THE PRESS CORPS
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
BIG ORANGE GONE FOREVER.
BANISHED TO MAR-A-LAGO.
LEFT BACK IN POWER.
ORDER RESTORED.
LIKE THE 2016 ELECTION NEVER
HAPPENED.
LIKE IT WAS ALL A BAD DREAM.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING
FOR CHRISTMAS THIS YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM,
SANTA GOT DELAYED.
THEY'RE NOT GETTING A PONY
THIS YEAR.
THEY'RE GETTING A BAG OF
HAIR.
INSTEAD OF DESTROYING TRUMP,
IMPEACHMENT APPEARS TO HAVE
MADE HIM EVEN STRONGER LIKE
GODZILLA, PARADING
BUREAUCRATS BEFORE THE
CAMERAS DEMAND THAT YOU SEND
MONEY TO UKRAINE, SHUT UP,
NO QUESTIONS ALLOWED, ISN'T
VERY EFFECTIVE AS A CAMPAIGN
STRATEGY.
AS A RESULT, SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHMENT HAS FALLEN EVEN
AMONG CORE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS.
HERE'S THE LATEST EXAMPLE.
EMERSON POLL RELEASED LAST
WEEK AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS, FOR EXAMPLE, JUST
37% NOW SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT
38% ARE OPPOSED.
WHILE 25% ARE UNCERTAIN
WHICH ITSELF IS SIGNIFICANT.
SAME POLL AMONG WHITE VOTERS
44% SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
NOT JUST WHITE DEMOCRATS
THAT'S WHITE VOTERS.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
SECOND, AFRICAN-AMERICANS
REMAIN THE MOST LOYAL
DEMOCRATIC CONSTITUENCY TEND
TO BE MORE SKEPTICAL OF
IMPEACHMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IT IS WHITE
LIBERALS HOWLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THE REST OF THE PARTY, NOT
SO MUCH.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
AND UNEXPECTED AND IT HAS
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
SQUIRMING.
THEY PROMISED THEIR BASE
IMPEACHMENT.
THE PRESS TOLD THEM IT WAS A
SURE THING.
IT'S HARD TO BACK OFF FROM
THAT.
BUT, GOING FORWARD COULD
DEVASTATE THE PARTY NEXT
FALL.
NEW POLLS FROM RASMUSSEN AND
EMERSON BOTH SHOW THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING
RISING.
IF DONALD TRUMP COULD GET
EVEN HALF THE FIGURE AMONG
BLACK FIGURE THAT'S IS
GETTING NOW IN THOSE POLLS,
HE WILL WIN REELECTIONS.
THAT HAS CNN COMMENTATOR
ANNA NAVARRO ON EDGE.
WHEN SHE SAW THAT POLL SHE
TWEETED THIS ZERO CHANCE
THIS IS ACCURATE.
ZERO.
THE POLL MUST HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED IN THE HOMES OF
BEN CARSON, KANYE, THAT
SHERIFF GUY WITH THE SAT AND